what's up taste buddies Joe DeRosa
coming to you from an undisclosed
location in Austin Texas and I'm taking
time out of my trip here in Austin to
let you know that the live stream is on
and popping and happening once again I
know we had to reschedule but it's
coming at you the 31st of May 9 p.m
Eastern Standard Time special guests a
gargantuan battle lots of surprises lots
of fun it's going to be a great time
again May 31st 9 pm if you bought
tickets to the original date your
tickets already been transferred and if
you can't make this one which we hope
you can you can get yourself a refund or
you can buy a new ticket by visiting
moment.co taste buds that's moment.co
taste buds we're gonna see you on the
31st for the first ever live stream of
taste buds taste buds they coming to the
mic talking about the food they hate
talking about the food they like
gonna fight but only one food can be
right taste buds man yeah they're coming
to them hey welcome to
t-a-s-t-e buds we got a special guest in
the house oh we got a great guest today
baby the man the myth the guy I started
comedy with in Philadelphia Pennsylvania
at the laugh House on South Street me
and this guy were the only and brought
Rocco Stowe were the only three white
guys
Mike vecchione everybody great Mike
thank you guys for having me on yeah I
appreciate it and yes Joe we did start
you were great right away for those of
you that don't know Joe was on fire so
good right away
no we were all blown away by that oh
goodness this guy stage presence it's
just murdering right away I tell people
that all the time he was a shooting star
you know you just faded you know it did
real hard what you're seeing now is the
remnants of his success about seven
years ago yeah yeah
I remember okerson saying to me when I
was of my first year in uh New York he
goes you're gonna make it before any of
us dude you're gonna be big yeah
was he off no anyway folks listen
no but vecchione always wrote uh great
jokes you always wrote great joke like
you were like I think you're like my
favorite joke writer he's so good but I
wasn't but I wasn't I didn't have the uh
presence you had like I don't know if
you I guess you were DJing did you do
something you did something else yeah
the music the pre your presence on stage
was very commanding I did music and I
and I did a wedding DJing yeah you know
so yeah I'm an angry person I'm sorry
what did you just say I did wedding
DJing and I I'm sorry what what did you
just try to say and move on from three
you never mentioned that I don't know
that as a friend and you've never
mentioned it on the podcast did I tell
you something
I mentioned this like can I just tell
you something I was out with Q the other
night and I mentioned this to him and he
said to me we had a few drinks but I
don't think he's wrong he was like
you should announce on taste buds that
you will DJ three weddings in a year
and you know it'll cost you a certain
amount he goes you will potentially make
a living
DJing weddings for fans yeah
I I married a lot of my friends I
married I think I've done nine or 11
weddings and and people know and so I
started getting through my agent
requests for marriages that's hilarious
so this is like a reveal episode where
Joe reveals he's a d you reveal that
you're a priest yeah I'm a I'm a
reverend you're a I'm a reverend yeah
the Universal Life Church of the great
California area I got I got I became a
reverend in Kansas to marry my friends
at their wedding there that's the only
place I'm allowed to do it just just go
back to the DJing for a second and like
you're uh you're a Italian guy right you
know you you you're you you Italian
weddings you probably pretend a lot and
you know not a lot of people do it like
that that we do it that they do it like
I If you go to uh weddings in between
the goal posts yeah uh people have
normal weddings I don't know if people
understand the type of Italian weddings
that happen in the tri-state area well
this is a good uh segue into my a little
bit of a history which is Tony and
Tina's wedding which yes you know that I
did
and I played Dominic for a while as an
understudy and then I was Tony for a
couple of good years yeah dude Mike
brought in a taller Tony eventually dude
but you were the Tony I was the Tony and
Tony and Tina's wedding in South
Philadelphia 20th and Snyder Mike did
that
this is amazing but here's what's Wild
so many questions here's what's Wild
he did that before it like fully broke
he did that like before it was like a
big thing that everybody like he's in
one of the original my head was my mom
was blown he told me he would tell me
about it he would like come to the laugh
house in Philly and tell me about it I
was like I don't understand what you're
talking about like I try to describe it
to me and I was like I don't understand
I mean this is so amazing I have to come
back to wedding DJ yeah that's how weird
this is okay now you this is a shocking
episode This is Gonna Be shocking very
shy a very shocking episode now so wait
so yeah this is this is you wanted to
become an actor
now I want I was doing stand up I wanted
to be a stand-up but I couldn't book
every weekend so this was a built-in way
to have all of your weekends books so I
would book three weekends of Tony and
Tina's Friday Saturday Sunday and then
one weekend I would do stand-up at the
Spaghetti Warehouse and maybe a Thursday
at the you piece by the way this Beauty
Warehouse was a real place she's not
being racist okay yeah
it was a real place so I would do one
weekend there wasn't that much stage
time in Philly there was two clubs there
no at the time nothing now it's now it's
a you know now I said so why were you so
I'm sorry I'm not understanding why
because it was it's an improv I was like
this will help me somewhere doing improv
okay because and it's entertainment
people all know the concept of Tony and
Tina's wedding if you don't know it
basically is an interactive immersive
right uh Italian way Italian wedding
experience where uh you know all the
crazy characters hyperbolicious
storyline and you buy tickets and it's
like your invitation and you go to the
dinner as a guest right their wedding
and then there's all the actors around
you and you interact with them and speak
to them and everything yes there's a
ceremony there you ready for when I
heard that I never heard of like
interactive theater are you ready for a
trip you ready for are you ready for a
triple ball blow yeah because first
first ball was DJ yeah second ball was
Tony and team yeah I mean ready for the
penis to get shot on yeah ready this is
a shaft blow I was in the computer
heating show of Tony and Tina's wedding
called The Sopranos and it was a spoof
of The Sopranos yes I swear to God I was
in The Sopranos and it was a it was The
Sopranos was like on like 15 years ago
it's when I started when this was okay
okay yeah no it was on 20 years 20 years
ago comedy 23 years ago yeah okay uh The
Sopranos the the premise was you were
going to Tony's birthday party
so people played someone played oh
doesn't who did you play I played Petey
the gay nephew or gay cousin wait wait
okay we're not gonna be able to get to
eggplant versus stuff and I apologize I
wrote stuffed mushrooms right I wrote
that because I don't remember writing
that now anymore Petey wasn't in the
show
who what character was that they made up
a character named Petey who was the
flamboyantly gay cousin okay and what
was your explain to the audience
like did you didn't have you had
specific beats you had to hit other than
that did they train you guys to be that
character or did they just audition you
and say all right he knows how to react
just say this this and this and other
than that engage no it was most well
well for I don't know with I don't know
I go you go first because it was they
were different shows they auditioned us
okay so you look you found an ad in the
paper yes well I knew I kind of knew
about I went to it years before they
happened to be holding auditions they
happened to be I I called my friend John
Vitale yeah John Vitale he's a it was he
was doing comedy and he lived in Upper
Darby wait a minute John wait a minute
why am I blanking on who jumped Vince
Valentine wait Vince Valentine was in
the surprise
the guy that played Tony Soprano in The
Sopranos no
why do you keep saying the so prano
that's how it was they it was like
spelled so pranos so they couldn't get
sued yeah yeah yeah yeah uh uh I'll be
right back to you just write Sopranos
dinner theater show it'll come up so so
so did you have to what was the audition
like audition was uh I I can't remember
they would give you a scenario and you'd
have to impress
you improving
it is you're still doing it
oh my goodness
Vince is an unbelievable I love Vince
Vince does Vince does and Vince does
caveman's uh yeah
hitting the caveman and he does still
holds comedy shows and teaches a comedy
club yeah yeah Vince's a good guy all
right anyway do the audition and uh and
it's improv and it's how good you improv
also your look matters you have to look
like uh whatever so you can pull off a
Tony yeah yeah like a queen but I didn't
get it for Tony I got it for Dominic one
of the groomsmen okay and then um and
then when uh the Tony fell out the
West Coast Tony moved to LA we called
him West Coast Tony because he came back
he's a great guy just had lunch with him
he moved to LA so then they bumped me up
to Tony did you feel extra pressure
going from Dominic to Tony there was a
lot of pressure thank you for asking
yeah and I'd also like you didn't break
down the nuances and the differences
between the two characters
were you the exact same character with
different lines essentially no you would
have to you know Tony's like you're
doing the ceremony so you're getting
married right and it's ironic because
I've never been married did you have to
kiss you had to kiss yeah every single
wedding you had to kiss every single
wedding is she a looker all the tinas
were wow it was a it was a stage kiss it
was a stage kiss but you touched lips
though oh you you have to I mean you're
acting you have to convince right you
know okay so did they make you audition
for Tony no well they knew you didn't
yes
[Music]
okay and then tell me about
how long did you do it
I did it for two years amazing so that's
dozens and dozens and dozens of shows
tons tons and it was so like can I just
say something about the the show was
pretty I don't know if it's still going
now and now I know it's not in
Philadelphia anymore the show was pretty
hacky yeah it was just a very hacky I
couldn't believe at the time it's before
YouTube or anything yeah I couldn't
believe the people that would come out
for this it's like it they would pack
the place yeah Thursday yeah Friday like
Friday Saturday Sunday would be packet
we would pack it out it was I was blown
away by it and it's a very rough section
of South Philadelphia okay and people
would come and park and just they would
just blown away dude very hacky show but
the the camaraderie that you had with
the other I'm still friends with these
people today wow we've gotten drink yeah
we would it was we paid next to no money
so at night they'd open the bar and we
would just get hammered and then we'd go
to like bars in Southfield
it came out the end bro character and
you bowed to everybody it's just not
like that no it wasn't like that at the
end of the show we would come out and
we'd get changed and come out by the bar
and some people would still be hanging
out at the bar and they'd do pictures or
whatever and we just drink with them
okay did you have someone please Joe go
ahead huh no go ahead please no no so
many questions I was just gonna say
would he just wanted to speak to the
people that would come out we were doing
like basically the I don't wanna I don't
want to say knock off that sounds
disrespectful everybody was really
lovely and I'm still also friends yeah
stay with everybody
but we were doing a secondary version of
that show and it was the same thing
though it was packed we would do New
Year's Eve shows it was like people like
I remember doing multiple New Year's Eve
shows where people like this is how they
spent their new years yeah it was huge
you auditioned yeah okay and and I
cannot tell you what I did when I
auditioned I don't remember how did you
play Pat the gay kitty I didn't start
his PD I started as one of the henchmen
which is kind of like what Mike was
saying so there were henchmen with funny
names like salmonella sure I was
salmonella actually I was salmonella
okay so uh and the henchmen were just
you were just there as everybody had to
do table work during dinner she
everybody went table to table the
henchmen were just there to basically
fill that out but you didn't have any
lines in like the main show or anything
like that and then eventually the guy
that played Petey he went there and just
stood around in a costume
we did it too crowd work you'd go to
table to table and do crowd work right
in character yeah and then eventually
the kid that played PD quit or whatever
and left and they moved me into PD and I
I gotta say I killed pretty [__] hard
and I kept the gig you guys get
played it way over the top I was like
what I'd be canceled right now
if you get like a character sheet about
the history of how you're supposed to
act yeah they let you know that's
brought it also no they do let you know
there's a written background you have
yeah I played one of the groomsmen first
name Dominic fabrizi and he owned uh
um an appliance store and he had his
girlfriend his girlfriend was one of the
groom's Maids uh named Donna Dominic and
Donna and uh she was like a gum chewing
like whatever and he owns an appliance
store and was kind of like a thug so
that was the backstory is that all they
gave you and then you came in and you
were like you made up The Appliance
Store you know the appliance stores
that's the back story but then you have
to that people yell hey Dominic can I
get a um can I get a deal on a
dishwasher
you gotta go yeah I got you yeah
it's like it's like you play with the
backstory yeah so so how did you play
the gay person I wore like a feather boa
it was ridiculous I played it like but
uh so you went over the top like
flamboyant like completely like oh my
god sister
hours
a couple years I got paid you got that
dude I was an open Miker doing comedy it
was making me better as a comic yes
because I was I could think on my feet
yeah and you'd get like 150 bucks a show
which at that time I was like this is
crazy that I'm making money doing
multiple hours a night for two years you
would go and be like hello yeah yeah and
I write jokes for my character and stuff
friends will come to see you yeah dude
my favorite story was this guy Keith uh
one of the funniest dudes I ever met in
my life uh I
didn't go to his college but I took a
winter break and I lived with him at his
college in Westchester
and he was just a maniac like he would
he would drink and he he I remember he
made a diaper for himself and he would
just so he could just piss himself while
he drank he was just he was he was bad
he was so funny
and uh and he would always take really
goofy [__] to you he everyone said we
were really high he goes
what's your favorite meat I go steak and
he goes right now I'm obsessed with the
bird
you're just a funny dude he was just
weird and funny but anyway he came once
on the New Year's Eve show he came
and I went to the table and I was doing
crowd and I turned and I saw him and I
was like
[__] and then uh I just kept I just kept
my face on and walked away and then he
ran over to me goes I know you can't
break character you're a crazy mother
[__]
and then ran away so like yeah it was
like you you once in a while that would
happen Okay but I I always liked it
better if I didn't know anybody yeah
it's it kind of was weird right when
other people who would come would have
to understand what was happening it's
like it's a character so they would kind
of encourage you to just do your
character right not try to like okay
well let me let me answer a few
questions did you mention breaking
character I know that like some people
some actors that consider some actors
will never break character right I know
you're not supposed to Break characters
yeah you did it for two years it's
probably been a lot of different
instances that happen so I want to ask
you you know what's one of the funniest
things or craziest things that's ever
happened one of the wackiest things that
would have been said to you or have did
women try to hit on you and for real
yeah I want all the little fun stuff
that people might ask did you ever see
anything crazy go down did you ever
break character answer this answer never
broke never broke Joe do you have a
great character I didn't but I have the
I have the best story ever okay and I
already wanted to tell this okay
this question my buddy Lev
he was one of the henchmen and then if I
wasn't available he would play Petey
and I wasn't available uh one weekend
and he was doing it
and he's going around you know
doing the thing at the tables and
they're they're in Northeast Philly and
this this this
Meathead from Northeast Philly keeps
like messing with them at the table and
he's going like hey come here little
sweetie come on little sweetie you know
what he's doing you know and he keeps
like proud and proud and proud and proud
right
walks over the guy behind him he walks
up behind him leans down he leans down
into the guy's ear
completely completely breaks character
and goes hey buddy I don't know if you
realize this this is just a show I will
beat the [__] [__] out of you and the
guy went daughter when he got fired
[Laughter]
outside you have to go right down
to Joe and then Petey put the plot of
The Sopranos was that somebody's trying
to whack Tony yeah and it's like a
mystery and Petey the pig guard plays a
pivotal part in that and they had to
just on the Fly Like switch everything
because they fired him and dude I I've
laughed about that that's hilarious
stories so many times they fired him we
had something like that too where the
guy playing Tony at the time I was
playing Dominic a guy did something like
that to him and he after he waited till
the show was over he goes dude I'm gonna
go and I'm gonna I don't care what
happens I'm gonna go attack these guys
they were messing with me and I was like
all right I'll go I'll go so about like
three of us went and he confronted the
two or three guys and then we were all
standing there and then the guy
completely backpedaled he completely
backped him once he saw that oh these
guys aren't actors anymore these guys
are very serious oh my God he completely
backpedaled man he's like you didn't
tell me when I'm ringtone
hey and it was hilarious but no one got
that's so funny getting fired mid-show
dude it was it made me laugh you never
laughed something that made you laugh or
didn't you laughed in car we used to so
thought about that time period for so
long I just what sticks out of my memory
is how fun it was and how we all used to
go out after and we'd go to the like the
worst I was dating a girl who lived two
blocks over in South Philadelphia and
she would go out to like Center City
high class like you know higher class
clubs and lounges and stuff and she's
like why don't you meet me there I'm
like no are you kidding me the drinks
are so cheap I'm drinking for free first
of all and then I'm gonna go to these
South Philly dive bars but like some of
them are like bikers and stuff like they
hang out in them you know what I mean
like they were and and one time like we
were at this bar and uh we left and then
a guy we were with was still there and
this biker just started like flicking
ice at him and like just I hate when
biking yeah yeah just like just teeing
off this I had to drove him out of the
bar
you're bringing back so many memories
because we did the same thing it was
like the camaraderie we all would drink
and hang out yeah did you guys sneak you
talk to each other during it like out of
character yeah all the time yeah yeah
yeah you could go off into the corner
whatever the the thing that would always
make me break character
member chip jambrone yeah chip was in
the show yeah he was in Sopranos with me
it was really funny he was really really
funny uh and I still talk to chip all
the time but anyway chip was a guy we
started comedy with and um
we all there was a thing at the end
where it was a reservoir dog style like
everybody gets shot and you're supposed
to be dead and I would always die next
to chip because the way we were lined up
and he would she have like the it
sounded like a gun was fired or was like
yeah they played a sound effect or
something I don't remember and we would
be on the ground dead and Chip would
would take the leg that nobody could see
from the audience and start rubbing it
up and down my leg
like like almost like sexually and I
would start laughing so hard it was like
it was brutal dude he would do it to
mess with me and try to get me to break
every time we were on the ground but uh
do you recall like one of your favorite
like performances or like one night when
you were feeling particularly
playful or whatever like did you ever go
over that did you ever go over the top
well first of all who keeps track is the
director there's a stage director there
there's a stage and they keep track of
everything so they make it all you guys
are on the up and up doing what you need
to do yeah and at the end on Sunday
night we'd have notes so we after the
weekend of shows we sit around
and they'd be like I don't like and it's
like typical actory stuff instead of
just accepting the note and it's like
you walk down the aisle a little bit
slow last time be like well um how do I
need to just go okay instead of just
going okay because the actors they go
well
um how what pace would you say is right
to walk down the aisle and then start
like an argument about being criticized
it's like just take the just take the
note whatever it is yeah we I don't
remember if we ever got notes or
anything anyone have a hit on you I met
a girl once or twice yeah it wasn't
afterwards I did meet a girl there too
and we hooked up and stuff I did have
sex after uh Tony I need to talk to you
after I had sex after the New Year's
show I remember
oh yeah one time I think I think that
was the one time that I hooked up as a
gay character you you hooked up you and
you get a girl hit on you yeah she
flipped you she flipped me yeah yeah
yeah did you did you did it get to a
point where you like going to work it's
like your paint is paint by numbers or
were you was it always like because it
was open-ended were you always still
excited it's always fun it's like doing
stand-up it's like when you do stand up
it's like I got shows tonight you know
you know how you think about it in
general yeah it's like I got these shows
tonight but then you get there it's like
hey dude this is great right right it's
never a bad night right stand up I mean
guys are Roofing right you know what I
mean guys are waiting tables like I'm
doing stand-ups right you get in the
moment speaking of which your special is
out right now ah uh and it was it's
called the on what is it the uh the
attractive the the unattractives the
attractive the attractive okay what I
think it was unattractive
attractive I was there when you taped
this yes and it was great phenomenal it
was phenomenal it was or a high level
comedian thank you buddy and absolutely
highlighting me that we all look up to
thank you I really appreciate it and I
appreciate you uh number one being there
yes and uh also all of your help like
sharing it and tweeting it and all that
stuff man I really sincerely appreciate
it of course oh yes I know you know that
that's sweet yeah
but Joe you know also so thank you uh
Mike was always an incredible incredible
joke writer this was God I was going to
say this 20 minutes ago we got real
sidetracked oh man with the Improv plays
that we did in about in the best way but
the whole thing was to get better at com
yeah what you did that's I need to get I
need to figure out how to get better it
gave me it gave me Immediate stand-up
confidence yes immediate and then once I
remember being so scared on the initial
shows that I did for The Sopranos and
then I remember there was a night when I
walked in and I realized oh this is like
I just like know how to do it now like
and I was like oh that's I remember
taking a mental note of like that's this
is a big moment like you're not scared
anymore like that like you know how to
think on your feet or whatever but
anyway
um like had a joke this is what I was
getting to Mike had a joke when we first
started
and I was like man that guy's really
funny man uh you were teaching I've
quoted this joke to you many times but
he was he was a teacher and he said a
kid came up to me yesterday and said
Mr Vecchio and if you don't pass me by
in biology I'm going to come to class
and stab you in the heart with a pencil
and I said if you can actually come to
class with a pencil and then locate my
heart I will pass you in biology
and it was just like a perfect like I
was like man that guy knows to this day
I don't know how to do that I was like I
never you were a guy admired because I
was like I always admired the guys where
I was like I don't know how to write
like that I don't know how to write a
joke right like you know how to write
jokes yeah you know like which is it's
just it's an impressive skill set well
thank you buddy but those were I haven't
thought about those those days where we
would go to these this open mic it was
an urban Club you know what I mean so
it's like we were the only handful of
white guys there but this is like early
2000 so there was now we I really
enjoyed it it's like there was comics
from the Northeast that other club and
uh they're great guys but they wouldn't
they wouldn't want for some reason they
wouldn't want to come down to the laugh
house because we got real audiences on
Wednesdays and real audience's good
audiences to be in front of really good
audience and it got us strong and and
the camaraderie of the other Comics like
it kind of it didn't matter no it didn't
whatever the black holes were very like
like two Ray would like if you were
doing good on a Wednesday he would pull
you into a Thursday it just depended how
it was all about competence right shout
outs to Ray Gordon shout out to Ray and
the legendary WID yes and Rod and Mona
and Christine and DJ all people that
that played instrumental roles in our in
our careers right to Ray I still every
time I see him I'm like you're my mentor
dude you're the guy that got me
absolutely he got me my first paid work
but uh but it wasn't anything it was
racial anything blocking white guys out
because there wasn't any of it so one
night uh this is so funny this was this
was racial
but it's a funny story
I was going out with Rocco one night
Rocco snow who you could imagine is an
Italian man shout outs to Rocco one of
our good friends funny guy
Rocco was taking me out somewhere in
South Philly it was it was when he still
went out drinking and stuff and he was
taking me somewhere South Philly and I
go all right hold on I gotta go get two
right he we're gonna hang out and he
goes Joe I can't take him over there and
I was like why and he goes sure I can't
take a black dude where we're going and
I go that's really messed up and that's
racist and he goes it's not me it's
where we're going
I don't care that is messed up and he
was like go ask him he'll agree with you
and I go to tour and I go I'm so
mortified right now
I want to bring you with me and Rocco
and Rocco's and Terry goes oh I can't go
over there
[Laughter]
that's fine I just he goes I got to be
honest there's some places I can't bring
you to and I was like uh okay
it was such a candid moment in race
relations where two guys were just like
uh this is the unfortunate reality and
uh we you know what are we gonna do
um but um it was uh there was such
there was like talk about cutting your
teeth yeah
you got to cut your teeth at Tony and
Tina I got to do it at the other show
and like you like and then on top of
that being the only so you're going up
at these dinner theater shows in front
of like these Irish and Italian lugs
from Philly yeah and then on Wednesdays
and sometimes Thursdays you're going to
the laugh house as one of the only white
dudes in front of an all-black audience
like like it was like get your [__]
together or get out yeah like there is
not time for us to think about right
what are you what's your angle and like
oh that was different or any of that it
was like deliver the goods or leave
right the worst I ever bombed was in
front of Italians I mean by far multiple
times in front of Italians like just
sitting there like
oh yeah just sucking their teeth going
yeah I don't I don't know I don't know
you know it's just it was just painful
oh dude
someone's like Tony
in the streets anyone ever see us Tony
uh outside of in that neighborhood
sometimes yeah yeah it's so funny it's
Tony it's it's Tony and Tina's yeah dude
like those Banquet Hall Show I remember
Jimmy Schubert brought me to this goth
fundraiser
it had me open for him because I I was
open for him at the comedy Cabaret and
he's like you're funny kid come with me
tomorrow this guy dude it was like one
of the worst bombs like holy God those
rooms could be so rough man like like
you know once you saw the once you saw
the banquet tables with the with the
with the pink linen
tablecloths and those tufted seats yeah
I was like uh Jesus man screwed you said
but use the right jokes for it you saw
my jokes for him when he did it oh for
The Sopranos yeah yeah you'd like I'd
have like my go-to
jokes that I'd say
no matter what okay you know what I mean
so how do you feel left out that you
don't have a dinner theater background
folks vessi shoes sponsor here at the
taste buds program
and happy to have him why because
they're changing the game and I like
game changers they're changing that
Footwear game people I live in New York
City you can be out at any time of day
and the weather can change on a dime
it's just one of those places and it's
also a place where you can't necessarily
get back to the apartment to change the
Footwear accordingly it's also the kind
of City where you want to look stylish
and you got to be comfortable all day if
you're walking around in New York my
Lord vessi has answered all of my
prayers they make a comfortable shoe
that is 100 percent waterproof not water
resistant waterproof that also keeps
your feet not just dry but warm they
have a lugged rubber outsole that gives
you the extra grip that you need in wet
conditions as a man who was slipped and
fallen in wet conditions in front of
women on a date thank you Betsy for
doing that they've got an added lining
inside for extra warmth in the cold they
slip on and off so it's easy to get them
on and get outside quick I like what
vessi is doing a super soft knit
material that keeps the feet warm in the
cold it's called uh it's made from
Diamond dime attacks
uh but it also stays cool in the warmer
months they've thought of everything
they've got you covered so here's what I
want you to do vesi are the go-to shoes
by my front door I want them to be yours
as well so go to vesti.com tastebuds for
a pair of vessi shoes you're going to
use promo code taste buds and get 15 off
your entire order plus free shipping in
many areas thank you vessi again
vessey.com taste buds use promo code
taste buds for 15 off your entire order
and free shipping in many areas folks
few things I love more than food and few
things I love more in that food
department than meat I love meat and I
love butcher box for this reason why
high quality meat 100
grass-fed beef free range organic
chicken pork raised crate free and wild
caught Seafood this is humanely raised
no antibiotics or added hormones ever I
love Butcher books what else do I love
it gets delivered to my front door it
comes in Frozen airtight sealed
packaging that means it's going to last
for a while in my feet freezer until I'm
ready to thaw it out and eat it it's
going to taste like it oh like it was
fresh today they
the day they made it
I'll do it one more time
what else do I love about butcher box it
comes directly to my front door it's
convenient I love that it's frozen and
vacuum sealed so when I put it in my
freezer I know it's going to stay fresh
until I am ready to eat it
also it's affordable gosh almighty when
you're trying to find these types of
meats that I'm talking about again the
humanely raised meats that don't have
additives and antibiotics and hormones
it's hard to find them affordably
butcherbox has done it and they're
bringing it right to you plus they get
even better because they're giving our
fans a special deal sign up today using
promo code taste buds you're going to
receive ground beef for a year plus
there's more twenty dollars off your
first order it's two pounds of ground
beef in every box for a year plus 20 off
your first order when you sign up at
butcherbox.com tastebuds and use promo
code taste buds putyourbox.com tastebuds
promo code taste buds
what's up guys we got some dates in May
June lie to round out the Impractical
Jokers tour and then more dates will be
announced if you didn't see it so far
all the tickets are on impractical
jokerslive.com these shows have been fun
and outrageous we've had surprises at
them May 19th 20th and 21st May 19th
Arlington Texas College Park Center May
20th at the Moody Center in Austin uh
May 21st at the Smart Financial Center
in Sugarland moving to June Columbus
June 2nd Cleveland Ohio June 3rd and
Detroit theater Fox uh the Fox Theater
in Detroit on June 4th oh man this is
gonna be fun schatenstein center in the
rocket mortgage field house that's
that's those are big shows June
um Minneapolis Des Moines and Kansas
City June 15 16th and 17th and then we
round out July here in Nashville at the
Opry on the 27th Cambridge Field House
in Indianapolis on July 28th and the
stifle theater two at two shows there in
St Louis on the 29th everything is
available at impractical jokerslive.com
and I will shortly be announcing
a second leg of my solo tour that starts
in July and will run through November so
stay tuned for that when is this coming
out pimpy
this Thursday okay so it's after may 10.
buy some merch check out our merch store
and check out salvocano comedy.com for
update as a joke writer we look at do
you do you write out your jokes like
what is your process well it changed
when I first moved to New York I would
go to these coffee shops before our
spots because it's changed so massively
yeah because we would do nothing during
the day we'd have day jobs we'd do temp
or all this stuff during the day to make
ends meet yeah and then at night you
would do stand up but you had no
literally no responsibilities during the
day right now it's like podcasting Clips
all this stuff it's like there was none
of that right available it was go hang
out at the club see if you can get on
right right so every nothing happened
until the night time so I would uh work
or do whatever during the day and then
before spots I would go to a coffee shop
and I would force myself to write jokes
before every spot I would force I would
I would force myself force myself force
myself to write these individual jokes
now it's more like it's changed where
it's like some podcast stuff I'll look
at I Journal you you know I'll take
ideas that are you know because there's
a thousand funny things that happen to
you every day you're not conscious of
right unless you're taking notes on your
phone so I'll journal and then look at
the journal and then take those organic
things that happen every day out and
then write jokes about those things okay
and I wrote a script during the uh
during the pandemic and I realized it's
like I would just wake up and just do it
every day and look at just get a Bare
Bones framework of it and then just keep
coming at it every day right and it
ended up
pretty good yeah and so I looked at that
I was like oh this is how I should write
stand up because I'm giving up on the
jokes too quickly right I'm writing
about topical stuff I'm just kind of
like not focused I'm all over the place
and you need a little bit of that but
the thing is like when you have topics
that you want to focus on and you want
to write a bit about it's like just wake
up do some individual like pre-writing
or thinking and then just keep coming at
it every because you wake up different
every day right so even if it doesn't
click one day you might make huge
Headway the next day right yeah coming
at the topic keep throwing jokes at it
keep coming at it yeah and it might
evolve into something that's interesting
I've never gone back to a joke every day
yeah I mean you know it's just like
right A lot of times I'll conceive
something I'll write bullet points and I
try to connect them making sure I hit
the bullet points right you know I know
the big swings this is how I'm getting
out of it yeah this is what I think is
funny in the middle and now I remember
that because I don't write things out
like I just I just like write the
concept of the blue point and then I get
on stage and connect it oh see that's
amazing that's amazing well I write it
out after the fact right then I go back
and I like sometimes I like to because
if we don't do a joke in a way I like to
have a record of it right right but I
I'd much rather be able to do what you
do
which is be able to sit there and and
actually concentrate and and be more
meticulous about it or or sometimes like
uh I'll have it in my notes now and I
look at the topic I'll just keep
checking in on it keep checking in on it
keep kind of or like I have this uh in
my album I did an album in 2018 called
the worst kind of thoughtful and I have
a whole 15-minute chunk about the
Megabus I love that bit and the how I
wrote is like I was on the mega bus
going to Baltimore or whatever and it's
like I was sitting on the bus and going
there's a lot of jokes here right you
know you could feel it before it's like
there's a lot of jokes here I just have
to find them yeah so just get a bunch of
coffee and I would sit on the bus for
three hours and then just keep writing
about the Megabus until it came into and
then it just evolved awesome yeah yeah
so it's like mostly tenacity just keep
coming at it it's great love to hear it
yeah from you great but I love the
writing on stage
yeah I mean Jay I mean Jay writes unsaid
I I I'll tag on stage but yeah yeah but
it's it's different process I'm more
storytelling you know so but all right
excellent that's excellent that's
excellent
what no nothing
I'm just listening all right I don't
know if you were like
what's your what's your process for real
for real for real uh we never talk about
it you know it's so funny we're all
we're always together we're always doing
spots we're always and I never we never
I never really asked like yeah I have no
idea how you come up with him
I have two primarily two ways of working
uh I I will sit and I will write
uh very much in like a monologue form
you know I'll sit and be like
you know uh you know the the the like I
want to talk about how the the the
Europe
I'll get an idea oh you know what you
know what Europe has that America
doesn't have ruins
they learn from their mistakes you know
we just build over them here so then I
take that and I sit down okay what am I
talking about and then I literally will
write a monologue you know two page two
pages on that and then take that on
stage and
you chip it down to what works and then
sometimes it builds back out again right
uh
but the most effective way I write
usually is pacing I Pace with my
recording app open we're all right as I
walk
I'll be walking through the city and I
don't do that and I go and I'll be like
I'll be like this you know what really
bothers me is you know when people do
you know what I mean and like talk low
like that and I do so I don't look like
it I mean I guess it doesn't matter
because people think I'm on the phone
but like I also don't want to be like
right yelling but yeah pacing pacing and
movement helped me a lot with writing
because it gets the energy out it
simulates being on stage and it starts
to help me organically feel
oh that's funny because now the
emotion's coming in yeah I guess you
know for sure
um I'm I I'm physical with my jokes too
right like I put my body into it and
sometimes I I don't know if
do you do that Mike I don't think I mean
you you got you you're kind of like nah
mine's like understated yes understated
punchline yeah I love the I love your
voice on stage thank you yeah it's great
it's really important it's really
something where people if crowds don't
get sarcasm I'll be like I'm using this
thing called sarcasm on you right now
please respond to it because you will
have a better time I'm going to keep
using it so that's what this is and like
you all need to spell it out and they'll
gradually like get yeah I guess because
sometimes they have to get you yeah yeah
bikes approach always was and you said
this to me once that you'll you'll like
with a bad crowd you'll stare at the
back
whoa right and just talk literally not
metaphorically or don't know anybody in
the eyes like you'll talk about why with
their heads yeah not not meaning like
because they're dumb right meaning like
literally I will talk over their heads
and you said to me once I said why do
you do that and you said because then
they can never say I didn't do my job
and I was like I wish I had that resolve
I can't I do the opposite I have to be
like why do you people suck that's what
happens that's actually better because
you're in it you're not that was me at
that time I think but now what I do is
uh I'll go up in front of crowd if
they're not feeling me you know you have
an hour and they're not feel they're not
your CR they're not feeling you it's
like just okay this is not going that
well all right but
it's it's let's ex let's be playful with
it because I find if you're having a
good time with your own act yeah they're
gonna it draws them in yeah you know
I've been I'm lucky that people think
it's funny when I get annoyed yeah so
especially like I've had there have been
fans in this podcast in my other podcast
that shows and the show is tight
and they'll be like what what's the
[__] problem in here people I
literally say that yeah what's the
problem because I'm not doing this for
45 more minutes and they they think it's
funny
laughing yeah
and I've shed to the crowd
what's the problem people with you and
then like like you you would abandon the
show no I'm just not doing it I'm saying
like I'm not doing this energy
and then I've actually said at times I
go oh oh I guess you're happy now
because you got me to flip out like I do
on the podcast and they like I'm like
they laugh and but I'm being sincere but
I'm like I guess I'm lucky look I think
anybody you me Mike it's it's not about
like this is what I do because this is
my tool it's like this is organically
what works for me to do in that
situation right you know very few guys
do the wrong thing in that situation
there are guys out there that will try
to do your thing or try to do what I'm
talking about or try to do whatever you
do when you're uncomfortable and and
it's not right you're like oh boy this
just went real size yeah just pull it
out because you have to release the
that's what everyone you have to say
what everyone's thinking you know and
then it's just like all right let's move
past it and isn't that the job of a
comedian sound to say what the other
people think yes it is you know to be
this truth teller what I like about
YouTube is you're uh your commitment to
it like you will whatever it is you will
commit to it a hundred percent wow you
go 100 commitment whether it's spiraling
or whatever it's a it's a hundred
percent commitment yeah I don't know if
that's a positive or A negative but
the
all right
uh Mike we're happy you're here yes did
you answer all the comedy questions we
all each answer the comedy questions I
feel like do we leave anybody out I
don't know about what everybody's spoken
to their process how they write yeah
right what goes on in their head what
got them started Sal's never done dinner
theater so it's never done dinner I wish
I did we have like a bartender though
did that help I think so yeah yeah being
social having to make conversation
having to make jokes
the uh what about what what Sal when
it's not going we've both said what we
do yeah that's what I was saying when
you're not when it's not going well for
you first of all is there a is there a
time now where it's not going well for
you at some times yeah and then what do
you do to get it back so you know so
people coming to my show obviously like
they're coming there for me so you know
there's a spectrum right so I know what
a what an audience is for me that I'm
like I didn't like that show but that
audience probably liked that show right
but when we're working stuff out or I'm
in the city or it's not my crowd yeah I
still hit you can hit all the bumps
right you know I um I do this thing
where first I do a thing internally
where I say
um well first of all you know how like
well let me you know how they say it's
never the crowd that's not true that's
not true I agree it's never the crowd in
the beginning yeah but after you're you
are right it can be the crowd yeah you
know so I do this thing where I'm like
all right this is the new ceiling for
what they're giving yeah so if you get
this
it's just expect that only don't expect
more than that right so then I lower my
expectations and then in my head even
though it's not going that great I I'm
not expecting more than that out of them
so I move the [__] goal post that's
pretty great yeah that's pretty great I
do a version of that where I'll come on
stage you know you have to ask the host
coming off how are they yeah and then I
I don't want them to like because if
you're newer sometimes you're like oh
they're great they're great I want an
honest answer yeah so how are they it's
like they're not good it's like thank
you yes because now I'll go up and I
won't expect it right so that's no one
ever says they're not good really
everyone's like it's good they're good
yeah but yeah so I do that and then you
know it's just about calling it out you
know I go just if there's a Heckler I'll
try to deal with them get get the laugh
move on right if they're still you know
still doing it you know I don't know how
much how much patience we have with that
but yeah no that's really it I'll call
it out uh that's the great equalizer
right you did knowledge that the joke
wasn't good right you have a laugh about
that yeah and then you just kind of you
know it's it's it's it's not that bad
when you're not getting that many
lessons remember when people are [__]
against you do you ever do a thing in
your head where it's like all right this
is not going that well let me see if I
could get them I've had that on the road
where it's like they're completely just
not really they expected something
different or whatever they're not
getting me it's like okay there's
nothing to lose here it's not going well
right and it could just end not going
well right but like who gives a [__] let
me try to let me see if I can just get
them and then pull them in without
pandering because that's different it's
like a line where it's like I don't want
to give the whole show over to them
right I want to stay Within Myself stay
in the pocket and just keep pulling yeah
keep pulling them in and let's see what
happens
all right ready yes uh all right we got
let's just let's just jump in ready
let's do the chant okay folks it's time
to be
[Laughter]
akionis here we're doing eggplant parm
versus stuffed mushrooms Michael and I
are team stuffed mushrooms Sal is team
eggplant Parmesan uh the reason we pick
these Foods is because when Mike gave us
his list of love and loathe Foods uh on
his loathe first of all your love list
was it was like the scramblings of a
scribblings of a Madman
the hell does he think we are in a three
block radius in South Philly he goes
roast pork Hoagie like nobody knows what
that is
in the peppers inside the olive oil
grocery store yeah yeah they're called
they're called pepper Shooters yeah
I heard them called pepper Shooters I
never heard that yeah right less less
episode less episode thank you last
episode we did we did uh Popcorn versus
cheese Doodles half the audience never
heard of a cheese doodle oh my God I
know yeah where was this Croatia yeah I
know yeah also also apple cake right
apple cake is not a thing yes it is no
apple cake is an absolutely thing we
pulled it up it's a thing listen wait we
can't digress okay here's the thing your
loathe Foods were a lot easier to latch
onto because you said eggplant well it
doesn't matter the other ones one of
them was eggplant I said so I'm gonna
explain the other one
okay one of them was oatmeal and that's
because if you eat you have oatmeal in a
bowl and then you have an empty bowl you
eat oatmeal and you throw up in the
empty bowl they both look the same I'm
not going to eat a food like that no I
won't need
[Laughter]
now is this one of the thoughts that
you'll force yourself to write about in
a coffee shop I will later this evening
I'm gonna have an oatmeal before your 7
15 at the cellar
you will I am surprised that you don't
like eggplant parm it looks to me wait
wait I'm knowing you yeah he real quick
though he said eggplant he didn't say
eggplant parm okay I agree to make plan
but then you were like we got a elevate
it to a dish of some kind probably right
we thought it would work better so you
said eggplant parm uh and then we pick
stuffed mushrooms but but go ahead go
ahead I'm just surprised that that you
don't like eggplant parm that's crazy to
me because it's a staple in you know I
mean my favorite food first of all was
probably Italian second maybe Japanese
Asian fusion yeah but one of the Staples
of Italian cuisine is an eggplant
eggplant and and when done right I would
disagree with delicious things I've ever
had right I would disagree with that I
think eggplant is a staple of of Middle
Eastern and uh Greek sometimes Greek
cuisine Middle Eastern cuisine it is not
a staple of Italian cuisine in fact
somebody sold in fried eggplant egg we
had Napoleon eggplant rollatini eggplant
Parmesan grilled eggplant red roasted
Peppers
somebody put uh in the on the phones
and I agreed that eggplant parm is the
thing they have to have on the menu for
the people that don't eat me everything
you just named there's a version of it
without eggplant and I think they're
working eggplant into a lot of those
other dishes to either egg of a
vegetarian option or B
uh hey we got all this eggplant we got
to do more than one dish Italian menu
and the Pizzeria and as it stands it was
way preceded needing a vegetarian
eggplant on top of pizza I haven't of
course I'm not talking about eggplant
parm Pizza I'm saying have you ever seen
eggplant just on top of pizza yeah Sal
I mean you could pull up any menu it's a
topping in every Pizzeria what are you
talking about it is absolutely not a
topping in every Pizzeria he's pulled up
hundreds of photos of it
you could find hundreds of photos of
Dick spots too I mean what does that
mean yeah but look at it yo you'll get
hundreds of photos whenever you Google
but you just said it's not [__] on every
you said on in every Pizzeria there's
there's it's listen it's toppings
Michael it's like pepperoni mushroom
Olive Michael I have not known eggplant
to be a routine maybe it's a specialty
topping but I have not known it to be a
routine it's not one like the core 10
like onion Olive pepperoni back pedals
because if we're gonna if we're gonna
backpedal into a Hawaiian pizza I'll
drop the mic and leave the studio if
you're gonna tip I'm not gonna look up a
little bit
I don't think there's no such thing
I've never seen it I've eaten it I've
had it I worked at a pizzeria I made it
hold on hold on I want to see a menu of
a pizzeria that's in this neighborhood
and I want to see if eggplant is one of
the toppings just the the advantage
claim that it's on every Pizza you think
what what's the while they're looking up
can I get to why I don't like it yes
okay so it's it's you're having this
blowout Italian meal my mother is gonna
make my favorite thing right so if I go
in and it's eggplant I'm getting all
Juiced up I'm getting all gassed up to
have the best meal of one of the best
meals of my life and there's a vegetable
down there the the main meal is
vegetable I I don't it doesn't it's it's
the eggplant
it just drops it's one of the only
vegetables that can pull that off it's
on an island of its own you wish it's a
meal eggplant is a meal I wouldn't want
it
the only time Sal is it a superfood
that's the argument
time I eat eggplant parm the only time I
eat eggplant parm ready yeah when they
do the thing on the menu or they go we
have a veal parm that we put eggplant
parm on top of and we combine the two
right then I do it then I do it I
appreciate it that it's there for the
for the people
for
the people
they also got a clampy yeah yeah I was
told there's no clam pies I was told by
Joe list that it doesn't
existence they got a Cake Boss Pizza
this place is going a little goofy okay
so come on I don't know yeah I can't
speak to the cake box but but I am glad
that the eggplant option is there for
the vegetarians okay and I do an option
for vegetarian I do not I'm not sure the
guy who made the menu let me just speak
let me just speak to what I want to
speak to about it it's I think I'm glad
it's there and there's a bite of
eggplant parm upset me absolutely not
but I will tell you what sucks about it
eggplant
parm
you want to talk about you you see this
thing you're like this is going to be a
wonderful parmesan experience you cut
that crust the breading slides off the
wet ass eggplant you're having bad egg
no I have I have eggplant parm that I
dream of that it's so good you just
gotta get good you gotta just get
someone who makes the dish well you have
your choice of the whole menu Sal and
you go eggs do you really I swear to God
when my girl orders eggplant parm and I
am ordering something and she goes do
you want to try mine I go save it wow
save it I know I don't even want to try
it I get this from my girl she goes you
gonna get eggplant again that's how much
I love like wow here's the other reason
eggplant parm stinks
there's an illusion that it's like
healthier
and it's like by the time it's you do
everything you might as well just had a
piece of chicken yeah no right nobody
and I'm not speaking Joe duroza speak
nobody calls eggplant parm a healthy
option I've never heard that in my
entire life no it's the only reason
you're creating a case to be contrary to
what that doesn't exist so you're saying
it's not eaten for being vegetarian
you're saying it's not even for being
healthy vegetarian you eat it because
it's not meat but that's not why it's
put on the menu by the pizzeria I used
to have a vegetarian option it is a
staple in Italian cuisine not like
vegetarian let's talk about it let's
talk about a great vegetable option
mushrooms stuffed mushrooms and here's
why they're a great option because they
take a mushroom which Mushroom on itself
I like mushrooms but a mushroom on its
own is whatever but you take a mushroom
and then you fill it with many times
crab meat yeah cheese and breadcrumbs
Italian flavored bread crumbs I mean
dude and it's that big you pop it you
eat it you have a few you're Off to the
Races you're ready for the main course
stuffed mushrooms are a delight a
delight there's an eggplant dish on
Earth it's the life we're talking
appetizer versus main course did you
guys realize that you've crossed over
yeah I thought this was main course on
main course but I mean I guess you could
eat mushrooms until it's a main but but
we are comparing a food here that is
good enough to be an entree versus a
food that is an app or side I think I
think a stuffed mushroom is absolutely
good enough to be an entree number one
has entrees then why the way that is
sized stuffed mushroom dish I I don't
think that that's necessarily true carry
its weight it's just something people
want that yeah stuffed portobello
mushrooms that's not an entree dish no I
don't think so why because my point is
if scallops are an entree I think
stuffed mushrooms can be an entree
you're I'm just saying I'm just saying
I've never I've never seen and you tell
me if you have I've never seen a stuffed
mushroom entree on a menu in my 40
something years on this planet no I
think Sal is right on this one it is an
appetizer versus a main course but I
think what salad is just willfully
ignoring is that mushrooms uh the effect
on gut health
we're going gut health here gut health
mushrooms you think that when you
stuffed that mushroom the gut health is
still a parent I think it well my family
who am I took my family had a mushroom
business in Northeast Ohio really
mushroom farm and Cannery so I'm glad we
uh that's not true it's true family
business mushrooms
well we didn't bring up the mushroom we
were talking comedy I didn't want to
interrupt the comedy talk even before
when we told you all right we're gonna
direct versus mushrooms family owns a
mushroom family a mushroom farm in
Northeast Ohio
mushrooms are a high profile
carbohydrate making them an excellent
option for prebiotics prebiotics nourish
gut bacteria while probiotics replenish
the bacteria well I cannot take it back
when you're stuffing it with cheese
breadcrumb and crab right I don't know
I'll take it back to Pizza too you want
to talk about Titan toppings
I mean mushroom is in top five of all
time pizza toppings there is always a
mushroom pie out it went in that little
window pies too no Sal there is not
plant pie sitting out in Pizzeria as you
walk in and you know there's not I swear
stop it I swear on I mean what you swear
on tell me what's around you you you're
not from Staten Island I guess that's
all
neighborhood
like plant is always one we did this
with Joe Lister he told me this
mushrooms the most popular pizza topping
in four U.S states Alabama Georgia South
Carolina that ended up being a dud no it
didn't yeah in four U.S states okay I'm
just saying you walk into a pizzeria
across this country with a window
display for slices you're going to see a
mushroom pie every time and you were
going to see an eggplant pie once in a
while stuffed mushrooms
do you eat when you're when you when
when someone brings it out or you got
dinner or your E4 E4 you cap it four
yeah okay how many and how much because
one what's that yeah mushrooms are
mostly cats yes you can before why folks
you wearing those sunglasses yet did you
break them out yet it's getting sunny
out there it's getting summery out there
go to Shady Rays for all your sunglasses
needs these guys are making high quality
sunglasses that are just as good or in
my opinion even better than the
expensive ones all right Shady rays are
selling at a fraction of the price and
they're high quality they're very
durable they're built to tackle all of
life's Outdoor Adventures the styles are
Timeless and on point and they make you
look good they make me look good I feel
cool when I'm wearing Shady Rays all
right Plus
all shady Rays have polarized lenses for
Crystal Clear Vision and strong sun
protection that's the real test of a
pair of good sunglasses I like shady
Rays I like to bring me cool Styles
affordably I've said it before I'll say
it again I lose sunglasses like they're
lighters or umbrellas you just leave
them places especially as a guy like me
who wears glasses I don't like
transitionals personally so I like to
have a pair of sunglasses with me for
when I'm outside and then I go inside
and I'm like I gotta put my glasses back
on I need to see
sometimes you forget that second pair
Shady Rays has made me sleep better at
night you know and quite frankly Shady
Ray's helped me speak Shady Rays has
helped me sleep better at night so uh
Shady Ray's IMPACT Program let me talk
to you about that uh it works with
non-profits Worldwide to make an impact
on the lives of children and young
adults like building playsets for
Pediatric pediatric cancer patients uh
we're creating Adventures for young
adults with cancer and Ms you and Shady
rays are making an impact together I
love when a company creates a cool
product makes it affordable and then on
top of it does something so charitable
and beautiful like that that's awesome
so what's better than getting one pair
of shady rays and not worrying if you
break or lose them getting two go to
shadyraise.com tastebuds use promo code
taste buds for a limited time when you
buy one pair of shady Rays you'll get
the second pair free that's
s-h-a-d-y
r-a-y-s.com slash taste buds and use
promo code taste buds codes to get your
second pair of shady Rays free
shadyraise.com tastebuds promo code
taste buds folks Joe derosi here taking
the summer off from live dates why I'll
be around New York City and where will I
be hanging out well you guessed it I
might be at Joey roses and if you come
through New York I hope you come to Joey
roses too we're open seven days a week
at 11 30 a.m every day and we go into
the evening serving food and affordable
drinks all day long go to Joey
rose'snyc.com for all details or check
us out why because because I really
don't want more than that oh well that's
nonsense I mean if I had it's if I had a
hundred right 100 stuffed mushrooms on a
platter
come when you come to my house the Super
bowl next right
if I had 100 would you eat and that's
all I put out but only because you have
so much other good food there but I have
to like I I don't want to you know spend
all of my appetite on one thing okay
before you got sick
that's actually a good question and a
good I think at skank Fest uh another
contest that they could
yeah
don't give them any credit sometimes
it's a nonsense that's like how much
eggplant Park it's such a heavy dish
I'm making a point it's eggplant parm is
the star of the show yeah yeah it's a
main question
here's where I'll shut it down mushroom
is a henchman here's where it shows up
instead
your argument down here's where I'll
shut your argument down you know what I
watch every single person that gets
parmesan of any kind do take half of it
home nobody can get through more than
half of it because it is so heavy
so you get a full second meal at home
but that's but my point is it's what
you're saying about the stuffed
mushrooms you can't get through a ton of
eggplant parm either I've eaten an
eggplant Palm sandwich to its completion
oh God you don't think people do that
you don't think people eat the full
scene you think you think I could need
10 stuffed mushrooms and and be fine no
I didn't that's not what I said I asked
you where do you cap it you asked Mike
and then you didn't ask where do you cap
it I could eat
12 stuffed mushrooms and then what
happens I'd say it would be like you'll
have sex in the parking lot
why not why not why not I think I can't
pull it off
for a second can I ask a podcast if you
don't finish this discussion you have to
take it for next time do you put this
argument in a doggy bag
oh he's always writing you know what
always right that's actually a great
idea for a segment we do something
called the doggy bag and we go we're
gonna pick up on last week's thing we
didn't really finish that's actually a
very that's a great and I have another
idea for a segment if I please sure um
by the way I'd like to be a pizza
correspondent if you if you guys if the
job ever becomes available I'll do a man
on the Street Pizza stuff okay we'll
send in send in the clip okay okay also
tell us where you find an eggplant pie
okay no I want to do another uh it's
another um
segment
um you guys can agree and then it's a
slap contest called uh slap the taste
out of your mouth
oh that's good that's it that's mine
okay
he is I don't like this I'm slapping one
as much
but I do like the doggy Bank the
doggyback what about when you pop one of
those stuffed mushrooms in your mouth
right yeah and you underestimate it's
Mass yeah and now you you're really
having an issue in there because you
didn't take a bite of it you could pop
them you said it himself you don't bite
them and we know we know that they come
in different shapes Inside Yes and
sometimes you get a little overzealous
and you grab a medium to large size when
you pop it in your mouth and then
mushrooms also retain some water yes you
know and then you bite into it and now
all of a sudden you're doing damage
control because it's shooting water
everywhere it's too much you can't it's
a poorly made stuffed mushroom I'm not
gonna let you have that if you're not
gonna let me have the eggplant parm
breading sliding oh I feel that happens
with even good stuff
Mike that is what are you doing no no
we're on the same team we are on the
same team but I can't discount
it's like you put it in your mouth and I
think what what uh Sal is really is is
you can't measure the heat sometimes the
heat is and then now you're juggling it
that's another one I'm talking about
sheer mass in your mouth but also
because at the bottom of that top with
different things yes yeah
yes yeah all right I also don't love
that it's a hand food
but if it's a big one you can cut it but
that doesn't uh Joe I'm on your side in
the sense that eggplant is a is a
garbage main dish it's just another main
dishes Let Me freeze it differently do
you ever make stuffed mushrooms for
dinner at home and just stuffed
mushrooms I don't make eggplant parm at
home for dinner but people do
my mom used to make stuffed mushrooms
sometimes is that the you made like
there's like 20 stuffed mushrooms you
sit with a plate and you eat stuffed
mushrooms for dinner we've established
that it's not a main course how many
times you're gonna go back to this
argument I'm trying to I'm trying to
understand though why is it not a main
course I don't know why are chickens
it's not good enough to be a main
question why are buffalo wings not a
main course they're usually just the
appetizer why are steamed clams on them
no people eat wings as their meal of
course they do people also me and my dad
eat steam clams and mussels of their
meal you go to most rest Italian
restaurants those are regulated to the
appetizer yes I think some things are
just you know I don't know people like
them before I feel like that you can't
eat that many before it's like I don't
want this I feel like that that's I eat
four like you maybe three five four
three
but then I don't my the move is you go
to stuffed mushrooms but then you don't
go to eggplant you go to a chicken
franchise you go to a veal parm you go
to something more stable something
that's going to give you more back than
an eggplant what I like about what I
like this is a major point for the
stuffed mushroom what I like about the
stuffed mushroom is it allows you up
front to get some of the guilty
pleasures of the Italian uh menu out of
the way you get a little cheese you get
a little breading okay you get some of
the stuff that's not quite as healthy
for you and then at dinner I move on to
a morsala or something that's a little
maybe wine based you know what I mean
something with a lighter sauce on it
something that's not deep fried I think
what Joe was talking about is how is
food groups a stuffed mushroom can have
all of the food groups and the entire
food pyramid well so I don't think
that's to be taken lightly I mean it's
up there stuffed mushroom is up there
with with a baked clam I mean it's just
unreal let's let's not not neglect the
parm fellas okay okay mozzarella and
beautiful red sauce okay I mean that's
put it on a piece of chicken you got me
put it on a piece of chicken yeah
arguing eggplant parm not eggplant I
understand that plant parm is phenomenal
you've got a lot of ingredients the most
famous food on the planet you got a lot
of variables in there that can go wrong
if the tomato sauce is not good you got
a problem if the mozzarella cheese is in
the right kind of mozzarella cheese or
it's not melted right or whatever you
got a problem I've had a lot of bad
parmesan in my life I think there's a
there's a smaller margin for error with
a stuffed mushroom is that you got
cheese in it you got the mushroom you
got crab crab by the way crab in a
stuffed mushroom
you're taking a you're taking it's a
risk it's a risk putting Crab Seafood in
the mushroom I don't know if I want it I
don't know if I wanted it now I'm eating
mushroom with crab cheese and crab salad
your parmesan argument though you say to
me sauce I say great you say to me
cheese I say great you know what I don't
want vegetable I don't want a vegetable
at the bottom of that
but a sauce is based in vegetable
the sauce based in Fruit tomato sure if
you want to but what do you mean if I
want to go I don't know what do you mean
and by the way
fine it's based in vegetable I don't
want it on
other vegetables
it's like saying oh can you add eggplant
to my salad
is innovative right you got Fried
Chicken colors yeah you got fried vegan
pellets chicken cutlets are just great
yeah you got that yeah you got the fried
veal yeah right all of a sudden here
comes a guy eggplant unassuming and he's
a vegetable and you're like well you
don't belong here you're not a protein
and then all of a sudden
he does the job yeah and now you're like
you know what now I have an option
that's not the same it's not just
breaded meat right let's let's go to the
phones because we're we're gonna have it
thick and you can it's terrible thick
the only way it's ever good is thin you
can see
right
stack it layers right nice piece crispy
Sauce Cheese piece on top of that peace
on
let's go to the phones and eggplant
Tower if you will and I have a side of
pasta
ready am I am I getting you am I coming
here
drop me in yeah and don't think that
eggplant rollatini it's not I'm not even
really two it's cheese and sauce as well
I'm not here he's like what do you mean
well directly I'm directly responding to
him no I know I keep shaking we go to
the phones I know but give me something
say give me a second all right
acknowledge that I'm asking a question
you want to go to the phone Christ
almighty we'll go to the phone no I'm
saying you could have said give me a
minute by the way by the way
let me just
completely unravel your whole argument
okay you don't want a vegetable as the
base of what you're eating right okay I
mean technically sorry what are you
arguing for
stuffed mushrooms yeah so is the base of
what you're eating here besides the
cheese and the bread crumb uh the crab
meat and the crab meat but it's a
vegetable we're not arguing mushrooms
but the
the stuffed mushroom the main
the main problem
is vegetables wrong telling me wrong
pass the cheese but you don't want a
vegetable bro doing the same thing with
that with the stuffed mushrooms wrong I
wasn't wrong it's correct it's not
factually correct the stuffed mushroom
is very equally balanced with all of its
ingredients that's a [__] argument
are you nuts that's a [__] argument
mushroom cap is the plate and you put
some stuffing inside of it the mushroom
yeah the star you're probably getting I
would argue you're getting more crab
meat than mushroom at that point the
crab meat lives inside the mushroom the
mushroom it's not cold the mushroom it's
not called mushroom crab meat it's
called stuffed mushrooms right crab meat
is this part of it yeah okay no no no no
no no no no so yes or no Joe is the
mushroom the star of a stuffed mushroom
is this the main component
is it the main compo yes yeah they're
called stuffed mushroom right yeah
but that's not the same component but
that's not the same argument as what
he's saying about eggplant Parmesan it's
two different I love the sauce I love
the cheese I don't want a vegetable
underneath because I love the stuffing I
love the cheese I don't want a vegetable
and they need stuffed mushrooms no it's
not no crab meat can't just yell no I'm
trying to tell you the crab meat the
cheese the breadcrumbs Elevate the
mushroom to something greater okay he's
saying you could have a Parmesan dish
with shrimp with veal with chicken the
worst option of those three as a main
course not an appetizer to use your
argument right back at you is an
eggplant and it sucks you're arguing
okay
you are coming to me with a Counterpoint
to a point I didn't make
I'm clearly making a point that he just
told me I understand I love it cheese I
love it I don't want it to be a
vegetable the main part yes that's
what's happening with the stuffed
mushroom and you just argued to me that
there's chicken there's veal there's
chicken the word problem is and the
problem is is because it's your main
course thing then the main course the
bulk of the main course becomes eggplant
that sucks yes I say stuff like the the
stuffing elevates the mushroom so does
the cheese and the sauce I understand
but you're arguing for a main course
dish that contains zero meat you know
what I agree it does I don't think it
does elevate the eggplant I think I
think the crab meat and the stuff
Elevate the mushroom but I don't think
it's I don't think and you know what
Mike I agree with you you're not taking
a step farther I was speaking I will
take it a step further
I don't think oh my God I will take it a
step further
the cheese and sauce to know how to
elevate the eggplant in fact the
eggplant degrades the cheese and the
sauce and I will go that far
absolutely not yes you said you love
cheese and sauce so by just just by way
of that inherently it elevates the
eggplant let's go to the phones because
I gotta catch a ferry in 21 minutes from
right now in a 12-minute walk eggplant
Parmesan is the only answer cheese and
breaded eggplant sign me up Gotta Go
stuff mushrooms eggplant is good but
nothing beats the Great Taste earthy
Taste of a mushroom stuffed that mother
all right uh we can have can we have a
third option because yuck we're seeing a
lot of that I've never tried either but
I'll pick whichever my husband Joe is
choosing thank you baby don't uh that's
in the parking lot
nobody want that LOL if that's for
dinner I'm a doordash Taco Bell or Baja
Blast Baja Fresh you mean
uh these dudes are having a mid-off oh
that's funny eggplant cooked incorrectly
feels like chewing half filled water
balloon
eggplant I love mushrooms okay it's like
asking if if I like disappointment or
rain clouds
where what kind of world are we living
in where stuffed mushrooms even come
close to eggplant parm
the one time they're they're so bad Joe
could get stuck picking either haha uh
I can't believe this many people are
eggplant haters good I thought that
there's a lot of eggplant lovers there
yeah
I wish this neither was an option
eggplant parm is hands down the superior
option this is wait that one's funny
this is like asking about a rather eat
puke let's give the wind to that that's
funny follow Aaron R at Festivus
underscore Mira kill with cl on the
spelled with just a CL no e uh all right
Mike plug away because we we end it real
quick once we go to the vote okay
um please check out my comedy special on
YouTube for free it's called the
attractives
um all I'm asking is that you watch it
and then share it with everyone you've
ever met in your life please
um it's already over a million uh thanks
to these guys and you guys so please
welcome back so [__] good very good
please watch it Nate land Productions my
good friend our good friend napar gatsy
directed it produce it it's on the
nateland home page please watch it also
I have a podcast called Mike vecchion
investigates on gas digital you could
please watch that on YouTube a debuting
every Wednesday at 6 p.m and uh please
follow me on all social media platforms
at Comic Mike V I have dates coming up
end of May I'm in Chicago at Zanies
Rosemont and the beginning of June I'll
be at Levity Live in uh New York so
please look for those dates Chicago yeah
and um live in New York and if this is
for some reason the first time you ever
seeing Mike here it's he's one of the
best comedians and you should watch this
absolutely absolutely absolutely all
right you ready yeah
here we go humble pie shake man this is
what we call Humble Pie it's also a fun
play on words because someone has to eat
Humble Pie when they lose okay yeah drum
roll at the 5153 oh my
God
that's a rematch is this the closest
we've ever had is this the closest match
we've ever gotta be yeah it's under one
percent difference yeah an eggplant at
50.9 stuffed mushrooms at 49.1 this is
such that if we check on it in an hour
it might swing the other way screenshot
that because it might be the closest
ever let's get a beautiful screenshot
you could use a very special episode
this is a very special episode can you
screenshot that and label it fake news
because I think the polls are wrong and
I think something uh can you get a
bigger screenshot in case we ever want
to cut it down I'm just thinking of
something can you get an even bigger
screenshot screenshot the whole page
no way mushrooms lose to dude that is
wild that first of all I was not
expecting I thought that I was it was
going to be a drubbing I thought I'd
plant was going to kill stuff mushroom
but I never ever ever ever thought that
it would be that close that is wild
which means it was a very good battle
yeah when something's that close it
means that it was a very I think that
you neglected the fact that eggplant's
son was colluding with uh Ukrainian
leaders and um it affected the vote I
was suppressed by Facebook I'll take
that W even if it's under one percent I
loved having you thank you and uh I love
you guys love you too taste buds they
coming to the mic talking about the food
they hate talking about the food they
like two Fool's gonna fight but only one
food can be right taste buds man yeah